dans l'actualité du jour de la politique
avec la signature ce midi d'un faune
interdépartemental d'investissement
entre les sept départements franciliens
elle est présidente ces collectivités se
sont réunis dans les locaux de
l'assemblée des départements de france à
paris pour créer un établissement public
interdépartemental
l'objectif c'est de renforcer la
solidarité financière entre ces
départements alors pour nous expliquer
ce nouveau dispositif nicolas landry
noah a rejoint en plateau bon sens
nicolas monsois grégory de la rédaction
de tv 78 alors pouvez vous nous
expliquer en quoi consiste ce fonds
d'investissement interdépartementale et
bien c'est une première dans l'histoire
des collectivités territoriales en
france la création d'un fonds
d'investissement entre sept départements
ce fonds sera abondé d'un montant de 150
millions d'euros en 2019 un financement
annuel pris en charge par les sept
collectivités franciliennes et une
contribution des yvelines à hauteur de
27 millions d'euros
deuxième contributeur ce département et
objectif financer des projets
d'aménagement dans les domaines des
transports ou encore des infrastructures
sportives
autre décision prise ce matin nicolas le
renforcement d'un dispositif de
péréquation vous allez nous expliquer
les termes dans un instant alors ce
dispositif c'est un fonds de solidarité
pour les départements de la région ile
de france et bien grégory comme vous
l'avez dit je vais d'abord expliquer le
terme péréquation regardez cette
infographie
prenons l'exemple d'un département doté
de ressources financières importantes
notamment grâce aux recettes fiscales
cette collectivité va verser une somme
dans un fonds dit de péréquation et ce
fonds va permettre une redistribution à
un département doté de ressources
minimes avec des recettes fiscales
moindres
vous l'avez compris ce dispositif permet
de réduire les inégalités de richesse
entre les collectivités et concrètement
comment se passe cette péréquation dans
le cadre de ce fonds de solidarité pour
les départements franciliens
alors vous l'avez dit au début le fonds
de solidarité pour les départements de
la région d'île de france existent déjà
la péréquation atteint 60 millions
d'euros par an les présidents des sept
départements d'île de france ont décidé
de la doubler à 120 millions d'euros par
an conséquence les deux départements
contributeurs
seulement les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine vont voir leur montant
augmenter pour le 60 18 le montant passe
de 2,3 millions d'euros à 6 7 millions
merci nicolas de nous aider à y voir
plus clair sur ces sujets complexes